Hi,
welcome back to human emotion.
Today we're going to talk about the way
in which emotions shape our judgements
and decisions.
And in particular we're going to look at
how they shape those decisions when it
comes to money. So can emotion really
shaped the way we spend our money,
shaped the way we think about our money
and shape how important money is to us.
So in essence,
we're going to be returning
to the question that we
actually address in our very
first lecture. Does our wallet
actually reflect our feelings?
Can money buy happiness?
And how emotions influence our everyday
consumer decisions that we make from how
to spend money,
whether or not to donate to charity,
how to manage our purse strings
during difficult economic times.
And importantly perhaps how to even
save for our future emotional self.
So this will be our first module in
a three part module and judgment and
decision making.
And today what we're going to do is look
into a broad framework that will help
guide our thinking called the
appraisal tendency framework.
And by doing this we're going to start
to answer the question of can ceiling
really shape our choices and in particular
shape the kinds of economic choices
they make and everyday life.
And in this we will be answering some
of the biggest questions that you know
behavioral economists grapple with today
as well as emotion researchers too.
We're going to do this by first going
over what is the appraisal tendency
framework and in what way is it relevant
to the way we think about making
judgments and especially
when it comes to money.
Then we'll look at some of the important
or supportive empirical evidence for
the appraisal tendency framework followed
by our takeaway questions and expert
interview with one of the most
renowned scholars in the field.
So let's start with the
appraisal tendency framework.
What exactly is this and who
originated it in the first place?
So here we turned to the work of Dr
Jennifer Learner at Harvard University who
pioneered this idea of what we now call
the ATF for appraisal tendency framework.
So I'm,
what I'm going to do is walk you through
some of the core components of what
this framework says in terms of how
emotions shape the kinds of judgements and
decisions that we critically
make in everyday life.
So the first principle of this model,
again,
which is a framework to help understand
how exactly emotions influence consumer
decision making suggests that indeed
there are two different types of emotional
influences on judgment and choice.
And these are called integral
and incidental emotions.
So integral emotions are the subjective
experiences of emotion that are relevant
to the present judgments and
choices that we make. For example,
think about the amount of fear that one
experiences and how that influences how
much you're willing to gamble, right?
This is compared with incidental emotions,
which are the influences of emotions that
we think should be a relevant or have
nothing to do with the kinds of judgments
and choices we make. So, in other words,
think about the emotions that are produced
when listening to music or you know,
bad weather and just how the emotions
may actually shape things that seem
totally unrelated,
such as the kind of music you choose to
listen to or the kind of judgements you
have about weather.
And so in other words,
the appraisal tendency framework here
is actually focusing on these incidental
emotions are again,
the kinds of emotions do you think should
have nothing to do with the everyday
choices and judgments that we make.
And in fact,
most people would deny that these
kinds of incidental emotions actually
influenced decision making.
Now what we're going to see as we
walk through it is that they actually
profoundly shaped the
way that we make choices,
especially when it comes
to economic choices.
So the second principle here of this
framework is this idea that it goes beyond
valence. So this framework
doesn't just focus on the valence.
So that is whether an emotion
or is positive or whether
an emotion is negative,
but instead looks at what we have talked
about earlier in the course as the
underlying cognitive appraisal dimensions
that are associated with emotions.
In other words, what are the kinds of
evaluations or thoughts? In other words,
that kind of cognitions you have when
you're in a particular emotional state.
Do you have appraisals of feeling that
you have more certainty over your world
and more certainty over the future?
A sense of control or a
relative lack thereof?
And we'll go through different emotions
that really vary depending on these
really vitally distinct
cognitive appraisal dimensions.
The third component of this appraisal
tendency framework focuses on what is
called appraisal tendencies.
So as you can see here,
it suggests that emotions give rise to
specific cognitive predispositions or
ways of evaluating the environment.
So an appraisal as we talked again about
earlier in the course when we looked at
different theories of emotion,
we know that appraisals are associated
with an emotion and will predict how it
influences both the content and depth,
whether it's sort of more shallow or deep.
Of the kinds of judgments we make.
Then we have this, uh, you know,
component called the
match matching constraint.
So here the appraisal tendency framework
really focuses again on incidental
emotions,
the kinds that we don't think should be
relevant to everyday decision making.
And again, the kind that wants, again,
most people deny that these
influenced decision making.
So here we're going to look specifically
at this category of emotions.
And finally there's this idea
of deactivating conditions.
So the effects of emotions on
decision making. Really Wayne,
when the emotion deintensify intensifies
or deactivates, and by contrast,
the effects of emotion should intensify
when the emotion activates or or
increases in magnitude.
So this is the appraisal
tendency framework that
Jennifer learner put forward to
really understand how emotions and
in particular incidental emotions,
profoundly shaped the kinds of everyday
decisions and judgments he make.
So what is the evidence in support of
this framework and how can it be relevant
to the of economic decisions that
we make in our everyday lives?
So here we're going to do is turn to
our second point on the roadmap where we
look at evidence.
Um,
and in what way evidence does support
this framework we just walked through.
So these are some really fun empirical
studies. Um, and one of the studies that,
uh,
Jennifer Learner and colleagues did that
was an empirical test of the appraisal
framework tendency model is testing
this idea of what's called the carryover
idea or carry over effect.
And again,
this suggests that incidental or
unrelated emotions may actually quote,
carry over to influence the way in which
we spend our money and make important
economic decisions.
So you'll see here in this article
by Jen Lerner and colleagues, um,
that she really looked at this idea, um,
called heartstrings and purse strings,
the carry over effects of
emotions on economic decisions.
And this is one of your readings and
we'll walk through some of the main
findings right now.
Precisely what way do emotions really
sort of have this carryover effect on our
economic decisions?
So what this study did is
it was first focused on,
um,
really leveraging off one of the most
robust principles and behavioral economics
that's called the endowment
effect. So, in other words,
people often place a higher value in
objects they own versus those they don't.
So an example is that people might,
will often demand a higher price on a
coffee mug that's given to them as opposed
to one that they did not own in
the first place. So in other words,
we put higher value on things that are
endowed to us versus those that really
are not endowed to us are
those which we don't own.
So this is the endowment effect.
And so Jen Lerner took this endowment
effect one step further and in her study,
as you can see here,
what she did is she looked
at three different kinds
of emotions and she studied
them,
um,
by eliciting them through some of the
most validated kinds of emotional homes
that we talked about earlier in our
lectures on emotional dissertation.
So she elicited a relatively
neutral or nonemotional state,
a disgusting state in a state of sadness.
And then what you see here in these
two different columns are two different
conditions.
So the first that you see here is what
she called the choice condition, right?
So the choice condition was,
um,
a condition in which participants were
shown an object which they did not own
and they were asked what price would
they prefer to buy this object for?
This was compared with
the cell condition here.
This is where the participant by contrast
was endowed with or given an object
and then asked again, what price would
they prefer to sell it back for? So again,
the choice condition,
they were shown an objects they didn't
own and asked how much they would buy it
for and the cell condition they were
endowed with or given an object and then
ask what price they would
prefer to sell it back for.
So these are some of the films
that she used to elicit, um,
the sad and discussing emotion
that were shown earlier.
And these are widely Lee's films
that we saw earlier in the course.
The sad film is a film from the champ
where it's a young boy crying over the
death of his father.
And the discussing film is from the
movie trainspotting where a man is going
through and digging through this,
like really discussing like feces
infected toilet. While he's gagging.
So these are films that have been
reliably shown to illicit both sadness and
disgust. So, um,
you can see just a little sample of the
film here for the disgusting film where
he's going to the toilet.
Pretty disgusting, right?
And he's digging through it,
gagging and most people weren't high
intensity or degrees of disgust.
I won't make you watch any more,
but you get the, you get the gist.
So what happened when she had people
view these different films and they were
assigned to either the choice or
the cell condition? In other words,
the questions she tried to ask in this
study is how can emotions elicited in the
lab using films?
Actually quote,
carry over to influence seemingly
unrelated economic choices, right?
How would that have anything to do
with these kinds of choices we make?
How much we're willing to buy or sell
an object? So here's what she found.
So this idea here, if we walk through, um,
in other words,
it's the question really quickly of in
what sense the era's depicting here.
Do these emotions literally carry over
to influence these seemingly unrelated
economic choices in both the
twist condition or sell condition.
So here's one thing that the authors
had specific predictions about when they
were testing this model about exactly
how emotions would influence this
endowment effect.
So they hypothesize that this emotion
of disgust that was elicited using that
film clip you saw brief from
trainspotting, um, would
have the following effects.
So discuss has this core
appraisal theme of, you know,
being too close to some sort
of indigestible substance.
And so as we saw earlier and we were
walking through some of the basic emotions
in our course, we saw that, you know,
the associated behavior of discussed is
really to expel objects away from the
self,
right and avoid taking a new objects.
So the prediction that
learner in colleagues made
is that after eliciting this
kind of emotion of disgust,
what they would predict to
see is reduced selling prices.
So trying to expel the object away
and reduced choice or buying prices.
So avoid taking in.
So for sadness,
we know the core appraisal theme is
a theme of loss and helplessness.
And the associated behavior is a
desire to change one circumstances.
So it learner and colleagues predicted
is that you would see reduced selling
prices and increased buying prices.
So again,
this is this desire to
change when circumstances and
really sort of remedy these
themes of loss and helplessness. So
here's what they found. So again,
we have the neutral condition in white
disgust and yellow and sadness and blue.
And what if you look at disgust in the
middle of what you see is that consistent
with the idea that discussed is associated
with expelling objects regardless if
you are buying or selling them discussed
really wiped out this traditional and
well established endowment effect in
behavioral economics by showing reduced
prices overall and creating no statistical
difference between prices in dollars
between the cell and choice conditions.
If you look on the far right though,
by contrast and the sad condition in blue,
consistent with the idea that sadness is
associated with a desire to change your
current circumstances,
sadness,
decreased prices in the selling condition
and increased prices in the choice
condition.
In other words,
individuals following a sad film
induction sold for less money.
And offered more money to buy or choose
the object. This is really a sense,
um,
you could think of it as
they'd be reversed or opposite
of the endowment effect.
So what you're seeing here is that
emotions can dramatically shift this well
established endowment effect that's
associated with both how we buy and how we
sell seemingly unrelated
objects. Um, you know,
that seemed to have nothing to do with
our current emotional state of feeling
disgusted or sad.
So we walked through the
appraisal tendency framework.
We looked at some evidence, some really
striking evidence that suggests that,
you know, discreet emotions,
even of disgust or sad,
can radically change the way we both
sell and buy our money and even reverse
some of the most well
established principles and
behavioral economics looking at
the endowment effect.
So now we're going to turn to our takeaway
questions to summarize some of the
main questions that you should
glean from this first lecture.
Thinking about judgment
and decision making.
So the first question focuses on what
are the core principles of the appraisal
tendency framework that we
went through today. Second,
what is the distinction between these
integral and incidental emotions,
disgust and which of these two emotion
categories is most central to the
appraisal tendency framework.
Finally,
what is the empirical evidence that we
discussed towards the end of our lecture
today and sport in support of this
model and what distinctions are rose for
discussed versus sadness.
And now we'll turn to our expert
interview with the true founder of this
appraisal tendency framework as part of
our experts in emotion interview series.
So today we'll be speaking
with Dr Jennifer Learner,
a professor of public policy and manage
management at the Harvard Kennedy School
of Government on emotion and judgment.
Dr Lerner is a professor of public policy
and management at the Harvard Kennedy
School of Government,
as well as the founder and former
director of the Harvard Laboratory for
decision science.
This interdisciplinary laboratory,
which she cofounded with two economists,
draws primarily on psychology,
economics and to study human
judgment and decision making.
Dr Lerner publishes her research
widely and scientific journals,
summaries of which appear in popular
print, such as the New York Times,
as well as broadcast media
such as good morning America.
She also serves on the editorial boards
for the Journal of Personality and
social psychology, organizational
behavior and human decision processes,
and the Journal of
Behavioral Decision Research.
She's received numerous
awards for her research,
including the presidential early career
award for scientists and engineers,
and in a White House ceremony,
the National Science Foundation and the
president of the United States annually
confer this award as the highest national
honor for investigators in the early
stages of promising research careers.
So I now turn to our experts and emotion
interview on emotion and judgment with
Dr Jennifer Learner.